we are actually today continuing this
idea of deductive geometry proofs with
vectors I know Ryan you missed Monday's
lesson you can catch up on that um when
we started off the idea and I gave a
couple of examples deductive geometry is
something that we are used to doing with
similar triangles congruent triangles
um properties of quadrilaterals and and
things like that right and using
properties and like quoting them and
saying oh um the base angles of an
isosceles triangle are equal right
that's that's kind of a normal way that
we've been doing deductive geometry for
the last however many years right
but what we're doing now is we're
exploring doing those kinds of proof
with vectors the reason why that's
powerful is because when you um say a
vector you'll you've you've got a lot of
geometric information just
um sort of condensed into the vectors
themselves because vectors tell you
Direction and they tell you magnitude
which turns out is a lot of what you
need for doing constructing a deductive
geometry proof so I've selected this
example because it is one of the really
good illustrations of where
um Vector thinking which is at least for
me it doesn't come naturally like I'm
pretty good at you can prove this result
Part B like the three perpendicular
bisectors of the sides of a triangle are
concurrent you can prove that without
vectors at all right
um and I know that because I've proved
this result long before I knew anything
about vectors like for years and years
right but the vector's way of proving it
is very uh number one it's efficient
number two it's quite clever when you
when you see it hopefully it comes out
you'll be like oh oh that's very that's
a really beautiful and elegant proof so
they have stepped us through you can see
they've scaffolded it quite nicely for
us so I think the first suggestion is
you've got your diagram there I really
hope you have drawn a decent sized
version for yourself you can actually
see see how the letters on my diagram
are so huge it's because I took them
this is a screenshot from the textbook
but I blew it up because in order to
work with it you really it gets busy
very quickly right and if you have
colors that will also be helpful I mean
it's not necessary but because you're
just going to have so many lines going
around it'll just help you distinguish
what's going on
so here's my first suggestion and I
wonder if you've already done this right
um You can see uh they have first said
let a b equal the vector U so you can
see down the bottom here I've got Vector
a b I'm going to draw it in
and here is the the direction so this is
called you
and then I've also got Vector b c so
I'll draw this over on this side here's
BC though actually I should have drawn
it the other way because the the arrow
is heading up so that's vector v
and then they give you a vector W and I
I looked it and I was like oh is it the
last side but it's not it's have a look
at it PL right this is actually let's
change color
um this is actually this Vector from the
the point in the center there which by
the way it's got a special name which
I'll tell you at the end this is the
vector W okay so far so good
all right now they then say find PN so
now I've got another Vector here
um here is PN just in here
and that's not very neat let's try it
again that's better they want this
Vector expressed in terms of uh V over
here oh my pilot is not working that's
okay this is V over here right and then
W which is the one that we just drew in
the middle there
now if you're like me um and in fact
Ryan when you first started looking at
this question you're like hmm scratching
my head right because they've given you
this other Vector U and you you sort of
initially when you read the question
you're like am I am I not allowed to use
you like if if p n can be expressed
independently of U which it can as we'll
see in a second then am I not supposed
to use you at all and the answer is no
we can use it as a stepping stone and
you're going to see how I'm going to
have a go at this okay
so here's the first thing that I want us
to understand if we want to work out
what PN is right can you see I've
already got PL
so from P down to L I've got to do one
more step to get over to n but it's not
actually drawn on the diagram so what's
the missing Vector that I actually need
to include here
what would you call that
it's um did I hear it right I think so
um it's it's Ln right can you see if I
had Ln
in there do you see that right what that
would do is I could say well from P to n
is the same as going from P to n but via
L like L is just a weird out of the way
stop off does that make sense
yeah okay so yeah I know it's very out
of the way it's like hey can you pick me
up I'm like you're not on the way man a
bit of a detour right L is a weird
detour but if you if you string together
P to L and then L to n do you agree
that's the same as PN yeah
okay so what I want to do is I want to
understand what is l n and maybe if you
have a look at the diagram because what
we've been given is actually as far as I
can tell it's actually two scale right
um which Vector do you see shares
something in common with l n
have a look
yeah the vector v right you can actually
see because the diagram is good now of
course this is not the same as proving
it we're going to prove it in a second
but what I want like in order to know
what to prove I have to have a visual
intuition for like where should I be
going right now tell me what Ln and
vector v what do they have in common
there's something they have which is
exactly the same
yeah they are parallel right now I don't
I'm proof that they're parallel yet but
using some pretty simple Vector
arithmetic I I can prove that they're
parallel the other thing is
um vectors are Direction but they're
also magnitude how does it look like the
vector Ln is related to V in terms of
magnitude what does it look like
yeah
yeah it looks like half a v right and if
you took a rule to it you would in fact
find it is not just like half it is
exactly half and we can show why so what
I'm trying to map out in my brain is Ln
is related to V but what kind of
relationship am I going to get here all
right so there's one last piece of the
puzzle that I need remember I said they
give us this Vector W right and you're
like uh is the third side why isn't the
third side core W right the reason why
the third side is not called W is
because you can express it in terms of
the vectors you've already got can you
all have a think about this right uh
what's a color I haven't used yet let's
go with pink I'm gonna use pink
if you have a look on the outside if I
go say and express
um which way should I go I'm just
thinking about the best way to do it I'm
going to go from a all the way up to C
what is this Vector in terms of the
other vectors I've already got
U plus v right because you start at a
and you're going to C with b as your
stop-off right so you do a b then you do
BC so this Vector here is U plus v is
this okay
okay now if you have a think about this
right what I can do is I can work out
what Ln is in terms of all the vectors
I've got here right so this is part a
I'm going to say Ln
what that's equal to is you've got to
start at L and you've got to get to n
via some of the vectors you already know
now have a look I've got colors here to
help you right to get from L to n it
looks to me like I could use the orange
vector and the pink Vector do you agree
like those are kind of um the directions
I need to head in but the magnitudes are
kind of all wrong right so to go from L
to n first I've got to get to a
and then I've got it and I heard you
saying this before Ryan then I've got to
get from a to M yeah
okay now help me out have a look at La
down here here's Vector L A what is it
in terms of the orange vector
a negative
very good it's negative half U because
number one it's going in the wrong
direction it's going the opposite
direction and number two where did you
get the half from like there's some
reasoning in there right
yeah L is the midpoint they tell you
there
um uh let's see PL is the perpendicular
bisector of a b so therefore that's why
you've got the the markings telling you
it's the same so that's good I've got L
A so I guess we could write that minus a
half U and then I have to work out well
what's a to n it's it's over here right
what is that in terms of the pink vector
yeah very good it's heading in the right
direction so I don't need any negatives
but the magnitude is half right it's
only going halfway up the pink Vector so
therefore I can add that on
and now you can see why the question is
asking you
um not to worry about you because can
you see what happens here can we just
expand this out what do you get
uh you can get a part of you that was
the hard thing
yeah very good so those two the U terms
are going to cancel with each other and
then you get the half V hanging out on
the end there right so in fact I just
end up with half V does that make sense
yeah okay excellent so
um now what I want actually is PM and PN
like we said at the beginning it is you
start from P go to L and then you go
from L to n which is the vector we just
worked out so can you all tell me what
the answer is given that PL was defined
for us
a half a minus W oh hold on hold on just
look at look at what PL is right look at
the direction of it
PL is already W right so I'm just going
to write w just there um that's the
first one I'm doing and then I'll do the
half V I mean not that the order matters
because it's commutative but I'm just
writing it in the same order as the line
above so far so good
okay now I'm about to do Part B yeah but
I just want you to have a look at how
much working we've done for part A
admittedly a lot of the working is not
um the symbols it's actually all of the
colors and the lines we had to draw to
reason through things but what I want
you to do is just sort of mentally take
a picture of what my working looks like
just count it right it's
um six lines six lines are working
I mentioned at the start here that you
can prove all of these results without
vectors okay I'm going to show you what
the non-vector proof looks like
obviously you don't write this down but
just compare it okay
yeah that's right
um in order to get in order to get the
same result for part A at least for me
my brain had to go to similar triangles
right that's how you can get the same
half V result that we did but just just
have a look because you're doing
deductive geometry the old way you've
got to quote reasons you've got to say
this is why this is and and like here's
my rationale for this right you just
have to write lots of words now there's
nothing wrong with words obviously but
the power of vectors is that a lot of
the language like uh when things are in
proportion with each other you just
divide one vector by another right or
divide sorry divide one vector by a
scalar and then they're in proportion
that's all you need to say right so this
proof is considerably longer than the
one that we just did here because
vectors do the they do the reasoning
work for you as it were okay